-Drew!
-Hi!
-Oh, my gosh!
We love you.
-I love you.
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
Thank you for doing "Ew!"
-I mean...
-You brought it back.
-I have this one little bag
of "Ew."
It's like merch.
-You do.
-And I have carried it with me
for five, six years.
-Every time you come over,
every time that you hang out,
you pull out this little purse
that says, "Ew."
-Yes, that's --
It was my way
of being close to the sketch.
And I wanted to be
in that room so badly.
It's my favorite on the show,
and now I got to be
a part of it.
-Come on, buddy.
-Thank you!
You know I love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I --
No, I know.
You had a big night
last night, my pal.
You were honored --
the Time 100 Gala.
You were one of the most
influential people in the world.
-I don't see it that way,
but I'm very glad they do.
-I think they do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've never been on that list.
It's a beautiful --
an extraordinary list to be on.
But, really, I got to actually
make the whole evening
not about me,
which is very much not about me,
but I got to really spend it
honoring someone else, actually.
-Yeah, here you are here
with Steven Spielberg.
-No big deal.
-Yep. Yeah.
-And Ke Huy Quan.
-Yep.
[ Applause ]
What's so meaningful
about this is, Ke and I met
on the set of "Temple of Doom,"
"Indiana Jones
and the Temple of Doom."
-No way.
-Absolutely. I came to London
to hang out for around a week.
Ke and I went
to the zoo together.
We hung out.
And, you know, I would --
I would spend my time
with Steven,
and he would just bring me
to work with him, and --
-How old were you guys?
I think I was like 8 or 9,
and he was like 11 or 12.
-Is that cool to be right here?
-And he still has pictures
of us at the zoo,
and we would hang out.
I loved him so much.
I mean, "Goonies," Data.
-Yeah. Hello.
Yeah, I know.
He's unbelievable.
-And he was such a good person,
and I liked him so much.
And there we are.
It's like, you know --
And Steven is the type
of incredible human being
that I think just wants to know,
like, all of his kids are okay.
And so it just felt like
this wonderful moment
where we could be like,
"Your kids are okay."
-Kids are doing all right.
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
You're doing pretty well.
I have so many things
to talk to you about
and congratulate you on.
You are nominated for
a Daytime Emmy Award, buddy,
for Outstanding Daytime
Talk Series Host!
Emmy?!
What are you talkin--
And then the show was nominated
for six other nominations.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah!
-Wow!
-Yeah, I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am fully convinced
that a cartoon Acme piano
is going to fall from the sky
and land on my head.
It's too good to be true!
-And you got renewed
for season four.
-Yes!
-Dude, what is --
how do you feel about all
this -- all this success?
-I don't feel
very comfortable with it
because it just seems
too good to be true.
But I will try to take it in.
-You put the work in.
-I feel very grateful.
You know, listen,
life is a roller coaster,
and if it's on an ascend
for a little while,
just try to enjoy it.
I think. I'm trying so hard.
I'm more used to,
honestly, tougher news.
Like, does anyone else
feel like that?
[ Applause ]
Like, when things are good,
you're like, "What's wrong?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I'm used to tougher news.
And so -- And I'm used
to working at it,
and I'm just happy that there's
some good news on the horizon.
It's great for everyone
who builds the show
because we all do it together.
I said, "I will never call
this my show.
There's no I.
It's ours and we.
We launched in a pandemic.
Somehow we've made it through.
It's a miracle.
-Yeah, buddy.
You're doing great.
-It's a miracle!
-You do a great job.
-It's -- It's --
This -- This isn't easy to do,
I found out.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I didn't think
it was going to be easy,
but I thought maybe my life
would help with some training.
You know, maybe --
Oh, I've been doing this
since I was 11 months old.
Like, "I'll be able
to do this job."
-It's a different --
totally different animal.
-Oh, yeah.
-When we were talking,
when you were like, "I think
I might do this talk thing,"
I go --
You're like, "What's up?"
I go, "It's a lot of work."
-You warned me, and -- and I
have so much respect for this.
And I -- you know,
look, I've also, like,
been on the other side
of interviews my whole life.
Not here. Like when you're at
a round table of, you know --
There's all different kinds
of interviews and conversations.
You're more of
a conversationalist.
You take the armor off
piece by piece, you have fun.
There's no gotchas here.
-No.
-And I just wanted to try
and sort of think about
what I felt like my whole life
and how I'd be so excited
if someone asked me,
like, a different question
or there was good energy
in the room,
or if it didn't feel
like I'm sitting here
asking you a question,
but I'm not going to reveal
anything about myself.
-But you get up close
and personal.
-I think I've indexed in
the complete opposite extreme.
-You get really
up close and personal.
This is -- This is you
interviewing Brooke Shields.
Look at this.
You guys are basically,
like, spooning, almost.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and we got much closer
than that
at certain points, too.
-Yeah.
-I'm on my knees, I'm hugging.
Here's Chloe Bailey right here.
Look at this one.
-Yep, yep. That's --
-Yeah, you're doing --
[ Laughter ]
You can't sit in your chair.
-No, I feel...
-You get in there.
-...this magnetic pull of, like,
you know, I -- I...
My therapist would say, like,
"You're not supposed
to be attached to things."
But, Barry,
I'm so attached to this.
I love doing this show so much.
I get to learn
from people every day.
I get to have
these incredible conversations
that I definitely
take something away with.
It's always improving my life.
It's -- It's profound.
It's fun.
We like to be silly.
It's whiplash comedy
because that's like life.
Like, the heavier it gets,
the more you want to laugh.
-But, yeah. But you're
interested in people,
and you're interested in things.
-I love people.
I love every human being
on the planet.
I'm fascinated.
And everyone has a story,
and every person is exceptional
and interesting,
and it is so fun
to literally get to be
a conversationalist at work.
It's the coolest thing
in the world.
-There's a meme
going around online
about how your interviews
are so up close.
-I know. I actually
really am into this.
-This one made me laugh.
Like, this one.
-Yeah.
-"The guest -- Can I be honest?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yep. Yep.
-Their eyeballs are touching.
-No, I know.
-I know.
At first, I was like,
"Oh, is this a good thing?
I can't tell."
And then I was like,
"No, this is awesome!"
-Yeah, it's a great thing!
-It's so much fun.
Can I ask you a question?
-Yeah, of course.
-Like, what's your favorite
thing about getting to do this?
This privilege, this crazy,
amazing world of a job?
-I think --
That's a great question.
There's so many great things
that come with this.
I think it's making
the audience laugh.
I think it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-See, that's the best.
And seeing their face.
It feels good.
And to see someone laughing.
Like, you know,
you have a real laugh face.
You have a fake laugh face
where you're like, "Ha ha."
And then if something's
really funny, you're like...
And it's like --
I love that face.
I like someone making
that ugly laugh face.
[ Laughter ]
-And connection, you know?
To be connected together.
-I love it.
I love the live of it all.
I mean, we did shows in COVID
with no audience,
and, gosh,
I missed you guys so much.
-I was here.
I came for one.
-And I've been, you know,
an actor and a producer.
And it's a really quiet job.
Like, you're around people,
but it's very insular.
You're kind of inside your head.
You drive home at night,
and you're like,
"What did I just do today?"
That was wild.
And this is
the most connective...
Like, there's a cacophony,
there's an energy.
Like, I'm not a musician.
I've never been
in a job like this.
And for our first year, we were
like cable access on premium TV.
It was just me talking to myself
by myself and, you know...
And now we have
a full audience and --
-And look at you getting
nominated for all these Emmys.
That's what I'm talking about,
bud.
-I'm just --
-Well done.
-I'm very --
-Well deserved.
And now you're hosting
the MTV Movie & TV Awards
live, Sunday, May 7th.
-I know.
-Are you ready for this?
Are you nervous?
-I'm so ready.
We're filming --
You know, when, like,
MTV used to, like,
bring you actually
into the movies
and the amazing films
that they would make?
-You're doing that?
-We're doing all of it!
-Oh, I love that!
-It's gonna be so much fun!
-That's my favorite!
That's my favorite thing.
-Mine, too!
And I loved it so much.
And they're the most
amazing people to work with.
It's an incredible show.
There's incredible people
coming.
And if there's one thing that
I definitely want to celebrate
in this world and life,
it's film and television.
-Yeah, movies and TV.
-Yes!
-I love it.
-That's what I want to do
at the end of the day, too.
-Yeah.
-And I just -- I'm so excited.
-Congrats on every single thing.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for playing,
as always.
You're always the best guest.
I love you so much.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Congrats on everything.
Drew Barrymore, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The MTV Movie & TV Awards
are May 7th at 8:00 p.m. on MTV.